surpopulation carcérale promiscuité
insensé flambées épidémiques épuisement
physique et morale voilà comment on peut
résumer en quelques mots la situation
actuelle dans les établissements
pénitentiaires français c'est d'ailleurs
avec ces termes précis qu dominique
simonnot la contrôleur général des lieux
de privation de liberté interpellent
trois ministres à travers plusieurs
courrier rendu public
elle implore l'exécutif d'agir
rapidement en dépit de l'extrême
violence de l'actuelle vague de
l'épidémie et l'application de nouvelles
mesures pour tenter de maîtriser la
situation sanitaire pas un mot n'a été
prononcé par les autorités sur la
condition pourtant très inquiétante des
prisons des centres de rétention
administrative des locaux de garde à vue
et des hôpitaux psychiatriques
le cglpl le déplore et estime impératif
d'alerté nouvelle fois les ministres de
la santé de la justice et de l'intérieur
un cri d' alerte justifiée au vu de la
progression des chiffres au 4 janvier 8
163 cas avaient été détectés parmi les
quelque soixante dix mille détenus
français 1029 parmi le personnel sur
environ 40000 des bilans qui ont triplé
en quelques jours les foyers et se
multiplient en témoigne la maison
d'arrêt de villepinte en
seine-saint-denis et qui comptait cent
soixante dix neuf détenus positif au
corona virus à cette même période sur
988 détenu actuellement le plus fort
taux de contamination au commis 19 dans
les prisons françaises livrée à elle
même la direction a pris ses propres
dispositions activités collectives
retirer travail aux ateliers supprimer
combinaison intégrale et masques ffp2
distribués aux surveillants lorsqu'ils
sont dans les bâtiments de détention et
aux détenus qui doivent continuer à
travailler par ailleurs des paroi en
plexiglas ont été installés dans les
parloirs organisations syndicales
demandent à l'administration
pénitentiaire de définir un cadre
beaucoup plus générale avec des
limitations aujourd'hui une véritable
urgence à prendre des mesures de bon
sens et de limitation à l'intérieur des
établissements et ça passe
nécessairement par une doctrine beaucoup
plus nationale qui soit prise par le
directeur d'administration pénitentiaire
lui même un plan global qui
s'apparenterait aux mêmes mesures prises
par l'exécutif en mars 2020 au début de
l'épidémie c'est ce que souhaite
également dominique simonnot ce qui
permettrait de libérer les personnes
détenues proches de leurs fins de peine
et de différer les incarcérations qui
peuvent l'être pour éviter la surcharge
dans les prisons et limiter les foyers
épidémiques autre point important la
vaccination
57,6 % des détenus ont bénéficié d'au
moins une dose de vaccin contre le coc
vide 1 contre eux près de 79 % de
l'ensemble des français au même moment
un écart beaucoup trop important surtout
en regard de la promiscuité qui frappe
cette population aujourd'hui
l'administration pénitentiaire engagé
des discussions avec le ministère de la
santé puisque les soins je rappelle en
milieu carcéral relève du ministère de
la santé et non d'administration
pénitentiaire afin qu'il y ait une
véritable politique un peu plus large et
un peu plus vaste peut-être
d'information de la population pénale
concernant la vaccination alors ce qui a
été remarqué tout de même par rapport à
ça depuis le début de la semaine c'est
qu'il ya une sorte de relance celle de
reprise de la campagne vaccinale au
milieu carcéral puisqu'on à une
augmentation de 10 % du nombre des
vaccinations par rapport à la semaine
précédente une des conséquences directes
de cette flambée épidémique et pour le
personnel dans les prisons elle qui a vu
une réduction drastique de ses effectifs
due à la multiplication de ces cas
contacts d'où une gestion plus difficile
des établissements le gouvernement reste
pour l'instant au muet et plus
particulièrement eric dupond moretti
pourtant au sommet de la hiérarchie et
pénitentiaire avec ces courriers
dominique simonnot espère inciter le
garde des sceaux à prendre ses
responsabilités